hey everybody welcome to Street cocoa
we're here today with Moses storm yeah I
like it look at this we it's a it's we
Moses amazing actor and comedian
I said actor by the way yeah I'll take
it exactly he was in respect what's the
amazing youtube series you're in how you
think consequent yes I saw he played
hook view actually I'm the hundred views
a little obsessed with that series you
should check it out it's on YouTube
Moses you obviously become a problem all
your cast members I know Velma team cast
me it's weird I got this tattoo I'm
hoping you'll sign up later Moses as you
all well know hosted our with Chris read
hosted our comic-con live pre-shows last
year and now we're starting something
very exciting and new tonight with Moses
tell Mauresmo it's the up and up it's
the first team cocoa live show that's
happening yes monthly so it's it's all
the team cocoa people putting it
together and it's a live show that's
happening in Los Angeles with all people
from the the Conan show yes give him
give him some gonna be there is no
bigger friend
it's basically Conan Pete Holmes Andy
Richter right yeah exact number two but
a friend of the show where are you on
that list I'm not on that list
okay making the list I'm on it yes happy
honors I'm the puppet master I'm next
the lists and then we have stand-up
comedy from from Ron Funches yes
Laurie Kilmartin is a writer on the
shows very funny hilarious
Matt Braunger who's been on the show
many many times amazing and in someone
who's running their set who's about to
be on the Kohner [ __ ] that's awesome
so you're live you get you see
established comedians you see
up-and-coming comedian is there gonna be
a band
perhaps what that's crazy
it's really cool Eureka's going up and
up tonight we got a few on the chatter
ago and that's fantastic it's at a
theater called dynasty typewriter in los
angeles it's great bustling Koreatown
absolutely it's yeah I think there might
be some tickets still available that
there's a link in my bio yeah get him
before they're gone they might be gone
and you can get tickets if you go to at
Team Coco our Instagram there's a link
on that which is fantastic is that right
Beth that's true perfect that I just say
things no one thinks yeah I see pointed
Beth there's no person there's no person
it's actually me I threw my voice with
this whole time Beth has just been a
ventriloquist dummy Ashley's the reverse
she does the voice and I'm the puppet
that's there's no puppet alright so
there we go
Funches people are excited so we're
gonna play a game today about friendship
and teamwork Wow are you ready yeah oh
my gasps tone found at the bottom of the
ocean yeah like that and with as much
personality and it's this game called a
way out I don't know have you heard
about this game way out oh wow is this
the one where they Bri they break out of
prison yes that's it that's it and like
a good exactly like a good friend he
already knew what I was talking about I
believe it's like two brothers and you
know that's wrong no problem so I'm out
not even close
now do you want to be the guy with the
sideburns you want to be the guy with
the shitty looking goatee I want to be
terrible sideburns or a goatee Oh
terrible sideburns yelping mm perfect
all right so move it move your thing
over to the right if you'd be so kind
Leo and Vincent we're gonna have to work
together which is different than how we
normally work which is right against
each other hey Lex for me the creator of
this game was Swedish guy said this he's
so confident in his game that he said if
you don't like the game you can these
the real thing he said you could fly to
sweden and you can you could cut off his
leg with the chainsaw oh my god now can
I say I don't like the game just to cut
a man's leg off of the tree right
because that's on my bucket list right I
have a really weird bucket list what's
what's something that's on your bucket
list for real do you have a real bucket
list uh knows like places I want to
travel because I I know you've been to
Iceland I've been nice that's on my
bucket list
it's [ __ ] cutting off a man's leg with
a chainsaw yeah
actually one and two and then Iceland
and then it's cutting up another man
yeah like I'm really into cutting off of
legs I don't know it's the thing I'm
into I don't want to get into it you
know what I'm hearing is no sound on the
game why do you think would that people
alright so this is gonna work out well
because I'm on the left yeah so it looks
like we are just entering
yeah we're just entering in the machine
that's right well yeah so what we're
continuing a game that I said okay so
basically we I'm not so we're trying to
smuggle a wrench this is all part of our
is all part of our escape plan we're
trying to smuggle a wrench to our cell
we got to work together so I'm gonna
plane some wood okay there we go all
right I guess there's just no sound
that's all right
Heil Mouse I hate to do this to you
before you do that would you mind moving
the the box to the middle yeah I'm gonna
stop blaming me the wood I think you
know I never so I was a camp counselor
for a little while is that you want
riveting dialogue oh my god wow that's
amazing
meanwhile I'm over here banging a hammer
bang oh yes you bring down the attitude
yeah I think yeah there we go
so you're gonna go to the left in the
press square this doesn't look
suspicious right me just continuing to
hammer one thing one now there's a
secret room near the sawmill machine
says oh gee well you know what I'm gonna
check that out right now you talked to
this guy keep that dude occupy turned
down that accent oh right
come on man I'm just trying to do my job
here all right Wow a little sweet little
swapsies oh so now it's just us so
insane you were just in Tacoma as in
decor Justin okay and in Spokane
Washington speak and it's not Kane
it's can write spelled Kane but it looks
like yeah how you say is typical
Washington so anyone live there we did
now did you see any ghosts in Spokane no
worse as all the people oh wow is it
notable is it haunted there's one
extremely haunted hotel there the
Davenport Hotel it's one of the most
haunted hotels
that's right stay oh my god that's why
see there and I saw did you see the
ghost
I still zero ghosts really also if
you're a ghost and you're already
bending this bureau why are you gonna
hang out in Spokane well that's a good
go anyway that's a good point
you know what that's why I think ghosts
don't exist because um you know like
Brad Pitt's shower isn't full of ghosts
like you know you were just going right
I would immediately but would be haunted
yeah exactly I would just immediately
follow around like well I would follow
around like Michelle gondry or somebody
like cool or like Stephen King I'd be
I'd like haunt Stephen yeah who would
you hire is there a specific person
besides the people in this room because
I know you're opposed be like it would
be like my own friends just being out of
insecurity let's see if their time just
be really petty it's the pettiest of
ghosts Oh steams headquarters are in
harshness Washington says Australia W I
love x-files you know what I I do think
I'm gonna say I I'm not super into
ghosts but I do believe in cryptozoology
you know like like yetis and stuff okay
you know like stuff like like like
beasts just things they can never get a
good photo up yeah exactly like they
mean it someone always drops the ball on
right
yeah somebody like oh that's a flipper
but is it let me decrypt a zoo all again
like the chupacabra have you ever gone
on one of those hunts know you can like
the have some guy takes you out there
they have chupacabra birds
I'm sure if there's enough following
around anything you could yeah someone
someone has said yes I'm idiots
I love I'm present in but there's
there's Bigfoot extreme versions you can
go on earth I'm just doing I think I'm
just learning different tools different
wood shop tools at this point I think
we're just learning I'm there in the
real time how to work in exactly
Sasquatch is the unofficial state animal
of Washington the starsk ranch we're
supposed to smuggle a wrench to ourself
this is by the way exactly how we would
be if we were in a prison we right I'm
trying to call the wrenches right here
oh wait this guy is gonna be oh you know
what come on over here and talk to this
guy I'm gonna steal the rest my god
you're just making friends no I really
can't this guy maybe I'm his improv 101
class exam
okay man I got to bring like six friends
is it cool
okay I'm chatting him up yeah look at me
stealing this wrench well oh snap
he's definitely not gonna notice that it
was a dude just standing behind him for
right minutes where's my wrench all
right now we got to go back to the cell
we gotta get past the metal detector
with that Oh metal detector oh there is
right oh okay wait you want to go
through the metal detector they're all
kind of stand over this limo driver
who's guarding your burrs here wait
right I need to go to the airport can't
even check him up but can you just go
through I can go through any Mon over
come on over here man
see this is gonna work and went past him
the wrench passing the wrench pleat cut
oh man no one notices us over here you
know what this doors tell me so maybe we
got to go over here or something let's
oh no no no no you ass
Oh how did you know I was supposed to
come in there huh how did you know it
wasn't supposed to go in there no I mean
I think you are supposed to go in there
I wasn't supposed to go in there Johnny
you went through the metal detector I'm
real dumb you should choose another
partner for escape oh here you go
alright we have okay we got back to this
point all right now is there an area
where I can just go I'm gonna jog
oh wait investigate oh look at this
what's this oh uh Moses where can people
follow you on all your ass oh Sh
at Moses storm no one else wanted that
Nana so [ __ ] was very easy to come back
in the old I like that you're saying so
I'm kind of into it I'm into
abbreviating words these days right
you know like life full words okay yeah
you make something the character I loved
was a guy from first yeah I do look like
Dante from clerks that's very true be
here today
exactly with one of the trailer park
boys dreaming psycho Wednesday oh yeah
he does look like June yeah yeah yeah
the guy with the M I heard they're
making a trailer park boys cartoon
really yeah I think so oh cool you guys
check out the trailer park boys bubbles
why we're here we really plug at the
giallo parts exactly now wait a second
can you go through the goddamn metal
detector yeah what was this hatch that
he was talking about well I think you
got to open the hatch from the other
side okay let me get over there yeah ah
AP AP Master were playing this on ps4
it's called a way out and we're here
with Moses storm who is the host of the
brand-new live monthly comedy show up
and up up and up a dynasty typewriter in
Los Angeles California United States of
America I don't know the USO problem I
did find something behind here here we
go this is gonna be so great the hidden
wrench hello boom look at that
whoa that's really one of these these
bricks are just made of sugar I think
they're just sugar
just kicked it he did a light light
happened and he shattered a break time
time
oh he socks by the way let's get those
on let's see these socks there another
reason to come to open up tonight cuz
are you gonna be wearing these socks or
difference this is great this is a great
angle it's gonna be are you begin yeah
and these socks are yes yes yes that's
fantast
lovely socks except for the fact that it
tells you like what side is which this
looks like the mark 3 these are I ran to
you so the be decide my blood pressure
down alright now this is a very not well
kept prison there's no one watching us
no tax dollars have gone into this
prison lighting is terrible and we're
stealing a reg prequel the Super Mario
Brothers shite
alright legs really you know the drill
oh you Rika has a sock obsession what
are your favorite either way secret
spider-man that's true spider-man for
the knee down what do you have a
favorite how did you get into weird
socks I'm sorry
fashionable socks I have no personality
I'm all just a fun way to express
yourself it's a little me secret do you
have a speaking of Secrets do you have a
nice performer do you have a
superstition about your socks before you
go on oh not at all I've no zero
superstitions I do have a thing over
like I step right foot on the plane
first does nothing you just that's
clearly a superstition mr. zoo but all
the time I mess it up or forget it and
completely fine with it which is why
you've been in so many plane crashes
it's crazy I'm gonna remember that Aboy
do you have any oh i'm incredibly so
/ stitches I'm superstitious to the
point of embarrassment but but it's
weird because I have to be I'll do a
thing like like where like even ones
that don't matter
first of all none of them matter but
even things that like I'll make up on
the spot
hi this is what's called being crazy I'm
just gonna put up okay so like I let's
say things aren't going well in my life
which is 99 percent time I'll be like
what I'll be walking Austrian like if I
walk past this pole before that bus goes
past it then things are gonna turn
around and then I start running for the
pole so randomly someone watching me
from across the street just sees a
person walking and then just like
running running like why do I do that
it's crazy it's I just make it up on the
spot that's not a superstition like beat
the no it's taking exactly a small form
of OCD I would say I made possibly a
large worm sir these days I've gotten to
the point where I need to drink water in
odd number sips Oh No yeah so it's like
and that's weirdly made me start
swallowing a lot of air so I burp a lot
now yeah because I only can drink like
I'll drink it and I'll be like oh man
wait that was sit before I got a sip 5
and I swallow and then I burp guys it's
a mess if anyone knows how to for me to
stop doing this someone's like if you
did get your sips and everyone's like
what's on toast and then you have to
drink that drink oh yeah oh yeah yeah
well that would be okay cuz it's just
one sip it's a non no yeah but yeah but
I have to then do three let's do two
more toast I need to do it's honest guy
you know like um yeah hundred percent
alright I'm walking back to the cell man
maybe I'll do a little bit of a jog you
know get my cardio in so really get out
of the Sun oh I told them that there's
someone's dealing drugs down down there
so I got him away from this door no wait
I'm worried cuz there's a chauffeur
outside my cell that's your cell yeah so
wait do you need to come up and maybe
distract this dude for means you already
get passed here are you upstairs I'm
happy a path e-ink says to play or storm
have any two people call you storm yeah
that's cool yeah I got bleh yeah yeah
you really
that sounds like a no sounds like a
failed kind of yogurt right you know
like bleh bleh
do you have you ever been to prison I
have to think this long I've been to
jail to bail people out okay yeah I've
been to when my brother was in gym just
like you know not like prison he didn't
stab ya and perfect they call them storm
in there what block you in so uh yeah I
just started a rumor for no reason I
thought I was helping but I just started
a rumor that someone was dealing drugs
downstairs
no I'm I mean they're never gonna trace
it back they'll never find you again oh
wait prison gossip so you have the right
right yeah wait should we make a
checklist let's go
whoa whoa better wrench in your pocket
all right oh [ __ ] what oh no wait oh
[ __ ] that's not good I'm getting shook
down
oh I get out oh no I'm using my cell no
[ __ ] you're anything you can do yes yes
yes yes boom oh look at this move okay
Oh God
can you flush it down the toilet under
my bed
human horse drugs aren't allowed in
prison how would you know human horse
you are gonna flush it down the toilet
yeah oh you've behind the toilet that's
great got one of those toilet doors that
are so popular presenting my body
shake me down tag natural just dude be
Nach be totes nagy this prison whoa he's
getting paid really well look really
well he's my this is a private presents
one of those charter prisons this is
literally how to game if you ever get
incarcerated you know I do wonder about
that with all like the video games I've
played in my life I kind of like wonder
if there was an apocalyptic scenario how
do you think you would do like let's say
zombies it was weird Rosie for real how
would you what's your strategy how would
you do I think now in my head it'd be
like oh yeah I would I would do
everything I was you in a game yeah find
a bad go for the head yeah in the actual
situation I think I would panic and
forget all that and just start
apologizing about it or I would pretend
to already be zombified so they wouldn't
get me see that's smart like to use some
of that sick acting skills
yeah you've read that's great and uh and
just already particular guy there he got
me right be bummed out about this I
think that's a great strategy and that
has worked I think that worked in and
what was the my god assignment what's
his name
simon pegg yeah what's that movie I'm
thinking yeah a shaun of the dead you
that shot a white goo on themselves
their zombie go yeah they do the thing
that's seems like a viable strategy
doesn't hide in plain sight plain sight
I like that
I think there's are you drinking beer
cans of beer that's right they say never
mix you know beer and wine I say don't
tell me what to do don't tell me what to
do you're not my wife
you're not my yeah I do think though
I've always thought of myself as like a
very resourceful kind of tough guy I'm a
bad guy right yeah I have a lot of
ironic t-shirts I think I would do
fairly I think you're so gay with a
tough guy but then there was one night
where our power went out and I live in
this apartment building with an
underground garage and I had to go to my
car for something so the power's out and
so I go downstairs and it was all black
and the front gate was open I was like
oh my god anybody could be down here and
I was and then I I was faced with Nellie
Hills yeah this is right this is a
really be anyone down here and I didn't
do it I was too scared and I just went
back at me before I was like I'll get my
dialysis tomorrow you know I was like
mine that's why I keep my Dallas exactly
but yeah so and I was when faced with
the real situation yeah I was a huge
scaredy-cat no I think I would just hole
up and and die a very sad lonely death I
feel about all those like self-defense
yes oh yeah grab the back of their wrist
right when you're being attacked
can you come at me like this yeah do you
watch any street fighter streams there's
a commentator that's a doppelganger of
Conan I don't but that probably means
that they're Irish because every Irish
person looks like Conan well lost at
Twitter says I will do everything I want
to and then kill myself
the apocalypse oh god I seems like a cry
for help
yeah I was like wow yeah you gotta go
into hard counseling you gotta specify
their man that's a that's a strong
statement that's a great way that's a
great way out khc Stewie says Aaron
please take another picture for the
thumbnail your head is driving me insane
I have that effect on most women I think
what it is is in a photo in real life I
have a very large forehead I think I do
too you know what you got a great hair
thing going on my hair is being else
like let's all go up four into four head
you like this is like measuring sticks I
can feel the lice leaving my head
vacation yeah I don't know I feel like
my fort and my I don't know it's weird
there's a lot happening and then people
will say it's father's if you guys are
joining us we're playing a way out with
Moses storm who is the host of the new
Team Coco monthly live show up and up
yeah downtown LA go to acting Coco's
social channels for tickets there still
may be a few available tonight yeah this
verse shows tonight exactly we got Pete
Holmes we got Ron Funches Lori Kyle
Martin we got Matt Braunger we got the
band they deploy and and what else can
people expect me it's about comedy
perhaps yes from comedy very exciting my
first show so a lot of harsh transitions
productionvalue a lot of flustered and
then everyone else doing a great job
it's gonna be a really good show that's
gonna be amazing a lot of laughter
either by embarrassment or by a purpose
absolutely it'll be you know you it's
win-win that's a great thing about
comedy I don't really care you can laugh
with me you can laugh at me it's all
laughter to me right I don't don't I'm
laugh blind I don't have laughed - I
just weigh what's happening I'm using
this wrench.now perfect we're just doing
some tainted over we're doing some tune
ups here
yeah wack but just we're just fixing
this prison oh I have what your brother
calls a fivehead thank you that's so
nice see that's what I'm saying laughs
blind eye I've to say I've seen a lot of
handles in my day this one has to be my
favorite thick samwell tarly that's
amazing probably one of the best names
Big Sam are you a Game of Thrones fan
yeah I can't I cannot wait for last
season the next one is the last season
yes that's it yeah that's it and I love
I've always said like I love when show's
end because they make choices people die
things happen you know like I hate the
episodic you know like friends nothing
ever happens until the end and it's
always a double wedding you know like
right whereas like Game of Thrones and a
lot of these streaming shows you know
like Breaking Bad is a good example of
that like it ended and so they could
kill people off and things happen you
know yeah yeah same thing with you think
consequences you know like how I was
doing that show where did you go shoot
it in Ogden Utah
oh yeah it's about an hour north of Salt
Lake City and their main export is dog
food and the smell of dog is it true
yeah wow that's crazy they cook dog food
in that town it's one of the bigger
bigger companies that that's amazing so
the entire town the aroma is all dog
food did you did it make you love or
hate dog food Oh hate it okay don't you
open a new bag of dog food that smell
constantly cuz you know what I'm gonna
I'm not gonna lie I have eaten dog
biscuits in my life
College was a interesting time for me
full of experimentation you had to get
that sorority something
[Laughter]
I love like my experiments
experimentation in college just was me
eating different things I shouldn't eat
what does this lizard food taste like
instead of like anything with girls but
you know and this is last year when you
were hanging out around a lot of college
campuses yeah I'm on the extended
work-release program this is my 13th
year in college I take you know I like
to do I like to just take like one
credit a year yeah give myself a simmer
photography math yeah exactly what did
you learn by doing you think
consequences was there anything was that
your first YouTube bread series the
first like teen drama show oh yeah
anything because a little birdie told me
that you have a certain look that you
kind of patented perhaps Oh a certain
certain perhaps a certain move oh yeah
if you play like a bad boy did you play
a bad but yeah could we actually go
fullscreen real quick so in a bad point
any show from probably Dawson's Creek to
Riverdale all the shows all the shows if
anyone's ever a bad boy in in a teen
drama they'll do a signature move it's
in every single one in this one and that
is uh is getting exhausted from just
turning around are you the best way to
go from here to here it's a long way
just turn around
lawsuit first loves it it's a great move
and you do it very well I like how that
linked to youth the consequences in
there yeah heck yeah that's Beth Beth
yeah the Reggie look it's basically that
my favorite thing ever just try it in
your everyday life you'll have so much
more fun with your life yeah I won't
work that into my just current looks my
look catalog I think you're a bad boy
exactly do you have any other looks that
you like to do just in real life to have
any of their moves because one of my
favorite is this one can you go
fullscreen one of my fears this one the
and that you use this this is a prop
this is a prop that guy well like if
there's a some do you like you know
a crush on or something and they come up
to you have to pretend to not be
interested yes I have the I had this
because you know you don't want to
inside you're like oh but yeah hey you
do one of these I'm like I yeah yeah my
stars and garters it's like this I'm
like this like it okay like one of that
you know just a slow kind of look up
that's good
oh no it's not good it's terrible it
makes me know it's a terrible move oh
look but it's a move that I do often a
kind of a slow lookup like it's you
start what happens is you start with the
eyes you step I'm just didn't do it real
in the camera era what is it you start
with the eyes and then you come right up
like that
that looks really you're not close here
that was directly right oh yeah it's
terrible um I I had done that move
before where I pretended to be on my
phone in a Ralphs grocery store and I
saw an ex coming so I wanted to be like
oh I don't know for some reason Oh busy
I got a whole life going on why do we do
this because I was not looking and I'm
pretending to be on my iPhone I was like
also picking out blueberries feels like
this will be cool I like little healthy
I'm eating gonna use the blueberry move
yes
so I'm pretending to be on my phone and
loading up blueberries I have no
intention of buying just so much you see
it's like so nice I'm not looking end up
dropping a pack of I don't know if you
know this about blueberries but they're
probably the Rolly is it's so Rolly
they hit the ground and they go have you
not seen in the mummy come out of the
ground that but just blueberries
everywhere just a large pack for like if
you're making a pie they were Moses hey
shoulda said a real name but there's
like Becca how are you and then like
managers are helping me clean up oh man
and it gets even worse because the
plastic from the package because I tried
to save it for a drive
it's slashed my hand now there is blood
running down my arm over blueberries the
management you gotta come
report I gave me a gift card
buddy I don't talk about it anymore that
money's long spent and I'd like to sit
on the check stand why they like rap
night this height so your legs a little
child be intended to completely
backfired not pretend oh my god oh good
lord but follow this guy at Moses storm
yeah there's more of this there's more I
can't it's right covert cowboy oh my god
good lord yeah I think I've definitely
done some I mean my whole thing I've you
know bumped into so I don't know that
I've ever done a spill than a slice I've
never done the spills yes move it's
coming no I think he was it was truly
shocking exactly yeah oh I love this you
all should be fired really really Team
Coco we look high and dirty clothes
playing games probably on the clock yeah
no I agree
oh yeah but here's the thing we come in
and they pre dirty argh yeah yeah to be
fair come in in $4,000 suits you to
relate to the people that are on this
stream so they throw dirt like a couple
of prison wardens oh man who's 25 and
you could be Blaise long-lost brother no
she was a way to send a photo yeah oh
god what do people say you look like dad
on family ties ah Newt Gingrich okay
when I was a little heavier actually
they called me Newt at work for a long
time when you work with comedy writers
it's not great yeah this was in the
early 70s I get a Newt Gingrich I get
that's it it's only the dad from family
ties and Newt Gingrich who do you get
who you get it's less celebrities and
more like people are like oh my god you
look just like my friend don't worry
she's beautiful
always the males always a woman oh man
I don't know I mean I guess you I don't
think you would make a beautiful woman I
think thank you yeah I mean you have
good bone structure I feel like no
visible facial scars unless you've
covered them up with prosthetics my face
is basically just one scar it's just one
huge scar yeah perfect it's like you
know the mel gibson man without a face
situations that's an amazing movie don't
look it up it's fine
that's right wait I think we're supposed
to one of us has to distract the guards
I'm happy to do it but I'm not sure
quite what to do no no that's well
that's what happened last time women
there's another way around oh wait oh I
owe them just go left I was stupid
that's what I'm saying Madeline sins it
takes two of us to open this thing I
think no wait come this way come this
way come the yeah yeah go over and they
take a left instead of going by the
guard that's right what game is this
arch Marlo I'm playing a way out which
is a game where Moses and I are you have
to play it with someone else this is a
cooperative you have friends it's hard
yeah it is that's the hardest part about
this game is the prerequisite is is
making the friend taking that leap and
exerting yourself up to someone yeah you
have to be emotionally vulnerable
because this guy's the last game he made
you played us to different characters
but it was one player what's that said
again the last game at this guy made I
forget his name he's a Swedish guy you
played as two separate characters even
though he was one person know the whole
catch of the game oh that's kind of cool
simultaneous under really convenient oh
that's what they chose to break out cuz
the weather yeah it's a perfect yes the
perfect breakout day almost your guy is
breaking down much cooler my guys really
not giving it I do work out my my delts
the old shoulders a bit right this guy's
like he wouldn't someone's lifting a
couch and they're not really doing it
okay perfect here we go I wish I will
say a seriously I wish there are more
moments like that in this game a less
distraction stuff and more like working
in together there's another part where
you have to walk up the chimney and you
both have your backs to each other I
guess this way yeah that was really fun
I would yeah exactly like a face hugger
and I wish there are more moments like
that
hey Joseph something I'm Madeline
Simpsons I couldn't play this game
because I know at friends you can play
online if you don't have any friends
right we can go on the internet and make
a scary friend yeah
oh we have to take this guy down wait
why'd they take him out is the first I
think so you kiss him
no II have my gum I help can we just now
can we take an embarrassing selfie and
like draw like a dick on his face or
something yes here we go I'm gonna
humiliate this dead body
uh yeah Shawshank Redemption I get that
yeah it's got a lot of Shawshank
overtones I easily gonna end you nothing
like a poop sewer God willing one can
only hope
hello from Washington DC hello smelly
feet seven wiry feet so smelly
I was recently in Washington DC and the
monuments the whole area is like a
really cool
you know well they call it the the our
Kate what's it called not the arcade the
mall mall come on right really historic
area where there's uh visiting and Iraq
warrants and there's school trips but
but no one tells you is on the weekend
the mall is just overrun with amateur
league like kickball teams do what like
rec leagues it is like it's like guys in
their late 30s that take HID bulb or
your left Marissa take some cuts and
they're like I this is completely true
the guy this was a kickball game or not
kickball is like rugby game but they're
playing huh and a guy he gets the rugby
ball and then there's like a veteran of
the English in a wheelchair watch it man
she likes the National Mall it's like
boy these people it's not for your
rectly that's crazy
this guy's bought a horse you could play
your kickball wait you're just doing
you're just getting some squats
yeah I'm just yeah I'm stretching my
back out open behind you some
cheerleading this is fine do you have it
so you being a stand-up you have to wait
how do I I'm gonna help you out see this
is the part where you need friends this
is this is the French all about
friendship my G look shinier first guy
there very shiny I think we're ready for
the club like boy band clothes
exactly oh here we go what's your
favorite do you have a favorite town to
perform it or should I say it's
basically the club with the city no I
like traveling in general I think
recently I like to Madison Wisconsin I
got college town there feels like good
yeah I did like I'm hard to coma arts
runnin said are you guys breaking out of
prison it seems now like we're breaking
back into prison yeah I feel like we
were just outside and now we're like now
we're in the library steal this rug this
is basically clue I think what's the
kind of globe where do we want to go
wait what close your eyes in point
oh my god really they don't know where
to go this is crazy this is like - 19
year old girls Chinese to figure out
what they're gonna do with their off
year
just close your eyes and blink
oh my god Uganda asteroid darted
something there was just kocha have you
ever been at Coachella yes I that voice
made me immediately yes I have I've just
outgrown it of like I don't want to do
that yeah I went for like maybe three
years in a row oh my god I got it go
tell a veteran I never did the camping
thing the camping at Coachella I don't
have you guys on that I need gross I
have not done I've only been to one
giant festival like that was Bonnaroo
that's cuz you're performing there and
so we had like an air-conditioned bus
that's so I've never done the Hulk
it feels awful I can't imagine getting
drunk and then having to camp and then
get up again and not you know right
right day one it's fun it's like oh we
don't have to walk back to a hotel we
just came here yes but it is like
Saturday at Coachella it's it's it's a
thousand degrees and there's a mile long
line for the shower
oh my there's a show there are showers
but they're like military showers where
you just like pull something down in
some water you don't have a clean water
it's gotten bad there's like also VIP
showers meeting like shower and
essentially a port-a-potty there we go
everyone's dream the porter shower yeah
and then you can see Beyonce on the main
stage she was having a revolutionary
yeah I watched that it was incredible
like oh no I also loved prostate Beyonce
for for reimagining your hits as like
like marching band style I thought that
was super cool
I love what artists do that it's amazing
because they you know they put the work
in it's like that's great you're doing a
festival like make it fine
like I hate I'm not a big concert guy
for that reason because I feel like oh
I'm just hearing I'm seeing you know I'm
in a crappy seat there's always some
a-hole in front of me and it's like
hearing the songs I've already heard my
times done better done worse and the
Beyonce performance as a stand-up makes
you feel terrible about what you do so
much effort put into a performance and
it's just be up there with a microphone
standing still they're not only singing
in actual talent and they're dancing yes
coordination and yeah come tonight to up
and up Moses storm the new live monthly
Team Coco produced comedy show and you
can hear his SunChips bit it opens it's
where you open with an you closer son
yes I open with it it doesn't do well at
the top yes I'm like I know people are
like yeah and then I bring it up in the
middle and then I do a video all right
it's a video conan video hard cuts out
it's me doing the SunChips the ladies
liquor you're eating into them exactly
the movies it French onion what's the
Sun Chips yeah the flavor you like the
most
you see these new some watermelon
already the premise is falling apart
like new SunChips
forties Sun ships in World War two it's
always the chips legals variety pack
some chips it's always it's always
Fritos and sunshine I don't know why
they even put those in there it should
just be cool ranch and and Cheetos
that's it let's be getting some deal
right some deal on SunChips yeah fill it
out with Sun Chips
how was filming unfriended it was so
weird because we were it was exactly
like the movie he shot where you would
we all had our own
cameras you know in a room we're all in
the same house though tell people what
unfriend it is unfriended is a is a
horror movie that was shot entirely via
Skype or at least the way it's presented
is it's all screen captured like it like
you just captured this girl's scream
while her friends are mysteriously being
murdered done trying to figure out
what's going on it was very weird we're
all in a house in Santa Clarita and they
had set dress the rooms to look like
different houses oh cool you couldn't
really communicate anyone to like just
like by the way we're communicating
right now is communicating so you're
like holding for audio pauses and things
you didn't hear weird
yeah incredibly strange and a lot of it
did not work what was the what ends up
is it a monster was it a person killing
at least like I think cyberbullying is
it yeah someone that got cyber bullied
at this oh god huge spoilers but also
this came out in 2015 so yeah you should
get on it
yeah the statute is I mean two years yes
just sort of thing its face time is
dominated the market someone has to yeah
if someone asked me to Skype it's
usually like a red flag about what yes
the way are we
is that our thing we're taking these
dudes on I don't know but crouching a
lot oh yeah okay ready Oh what where are
you here you can get a chance
double-team those okay all right what do
we do when we approach him cuz I got
just I feel like I couldn't even oh did
we get past oh no we have to start all
the way in the hallway again Oh again I
like this game but there's not enough
like partner stuff you know it doesn't
it doesn't feel like there's enough like
us working together thank you
now talking about Johnny Carson's show
do already
so I guess on the on the count of three
oh man no see what's they turn around
right away so what do we do wait maybe
we both have to double-team one cop and
the other one won't see it I don't know
take that sentence again exactly real
lord if this real Lord what is that yeah
Jordan sanski lourdes president yeah if
you haven't seen our conan italy show
yet watch it it's great yeah Conan
Jordan a lot of outtakes a lot of extra
stuff up online right that's right Team
Coco calm slash Italy my favorite was
the truffle-hunting disaster so clearly
set up and then Conan called it out
immediately he just that was hilarious
we had such a fun time doing that
because when counting are we doing one
we're doing one cop all right ready
which one the right kind of left right
yeah all right right guy there right
okay I don't
ready go
oh there we go yes nice
you took your guile real real good
fighter hey also what would use I
whispered in my Sun Chips wait what
straight down oh who cares what the side
ships are to kinda you can just please
leave this prison
alright this is very dark yeah out here
no and it's real dark we come down here
go to the right and go down the stairs
go that way
Oh oh no he said he said it after he was
in the searchlight that was [ __ ]
yeah sorry I got stuck reading your name
so I couldn't what is your name Lord is
Lord of Stan Lourdes Lourdes ah fair
game blue are you are you a video game
guy do you play video games uh not so
much anymore but yes heavily became a
problem did you know 2012 did you have a
favorite did theirs yes first-person
shooter so I would even say halos that
I'm a little shy so you're not a big
play on the road guy you don't stay I'm
down oh come on man this should be it
would be I think started Debbie it would
be better if they were brothers don't
you think there's a better backstory
yeah they could kind of snipe at each
other right if I'm a member one time you
crapped your pants that would be that
would break the tension
yeah the cutscenes could be us as
children and no one would wonder if it's
like a will they won't day which is why
now yeah I'm like okay why is he
breaking him out did they are they
lovers but if they're brothers just like
all we know what sexual tension is
intense right now not just in the on
screen but in this on this couch oh he
likes balls
Estevan a real lord
Estevan got it okay
what's the paper game to play with
countering ah I mean I don't know he
seems like he likes all the like battle
battlefront games yeah that's like
history I I think my feelings upon any
exactly anything it's like he's a big
war box yeah he's just like oh look how
accurate yes he likes like the life and
times of Theodore Roosevelt as a game no
I would say anything it takes itself too
seriously cuz then Conan makes the fun
of it in that way yeah anything that
gets too high in fantasy of like yes
orcs and yeah he's he's very into things
that take
- seriously and it makes it easy I saw
like Saints Row we can't really play
games that try to be too wacky we can't
really no I guess it didn't see oh geez
I felt like it was right on me it feels
like it's on me now
oh yeah that's like a nun excited oh no
you're like oh no oh no there's like oh
yeah battlefield one counter-strike go
Atari counts yes Tony a joke la or joke
Allah
yeah we're reading the chat we're
reading the chat oh also I'm trying to
hide for our lives you know and figure
out the sexual tension between these two
characters so what's going on right now
here we go I'd like to see a prison game
where you don't have to hide from a
searchlight you know let's let's be able
to have a suit little mirrors yeah he's
a mere shoot but the predator armor you
know something like that oh no oh no I
also like when guy when games talk to
themselves to tell us information right
like heavy-handed dialogue oh oh I
better use this to do this right I've
never said that in my life
all right get what's know what's naughty
wee-wee
naughty I know what naughty is this is
on twitch Faust you can also follow us
on Twitch team twitch.tv slash Team Coco
you have a twitch channel do you know
not yet enough people cyberbully be in
this channel you're a busy man you've
got a lot going on
our people are you performing going on
the road again can people get tickets
yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna be in San Diego
May 3rd whoo some college oh and then we
get the Denver Comedy Works no I'm
really excited about that's one of the
best rooms Wow in the country unless
that's uh May 31st that's you got a
little bit of time that's all right so
if you live in Denver you got time to
get the tix kids and of course tonight
come to go to act
oh nice I made it so far we were so far
of course go to at Team Coco any of our
social channels on Instagram Facebook
and you can get tickets you can find a
ticket link there yeah for this evening
you're gonna see a lot of Sun Chips bits
you're gonna see Pete Holmes you're
gonna see a good pal Ron Funches
Matt Braunger perhaps a Braunger a wild
bra or may appear is there any other
there's a lot of loose wild animals yeah
it's a traditional Moses storm show a
lot of wild animals mm-hmm here's the
ticket link oh there we go it's in the
chat thank you
I remember when I was 12 watching Conan
my old turnip TV it wasn't black and
white but it was close fuzzy and blurred
anyway I'm 75 now well thank you the kid
for watching when you were younger and
thank you for watching now you could see
us on this thing called the Internet
which is out there team cocoa calm Moses
will walk right through the waves of
bullies yes that's rad you know you're
gonna you're gonna be like neo at the
end yeah you just just like you know
that's stopping the pulleys in their
tracks and then kicking them where they
really stretch themselves far really
push they got cocky someone we could
build these characters with no spine I
do like a slippery no spine character
can we expect a clueless gamer episode
for God of War I don't know you have to
wait and see to wait and see I have been
playing God of War though and it's very
fun and beautiful it's about it's very
father-son relationship game you're the
god of war and you you're training your
young son to do to do things that you
beat it's a fight no yeah any but he's
like don't do it that way it's basically
like listening to my father give me
gardening advice get it know spread the
mulch like this I'm like yes fun so I'll
open this ladder off their guard check
oh great all right oh my god you're so
fast yep I need me up there you see me
creeping catch me outside baby
great then around creepy creeps great
back it tastes - take him out
do it you got the touch you got the
power yes it's Conan's birthday today by
the way yes you have to come upstairs
and say I wish them happy birthday oh my
god I want to help you can I help you
with that
tap tap tap
see the gangs make me think I could just
choke out somebody but I don't think I
need that easy in real life me neither
did I get any more like a hug yeah it's
more of like I would greater number like
he's that wire dude our belts haven't
you see tango and cash come on
well this also takes place in something
yes something um here maybe these
business cards we could tape them
together uh finally I used for a
business card people hand me a business
card now my what am I gonna do with it
what year do you think it is wait come
here and get this hanger yeah get that
hanger okay I get Conan a neighbor's
birthday no last year I got him a yeah I
got him a keyboard he's obsessive
typewriters I got him a grilling board
that was it's a big metal USB keyboard
that's like typing on a typer it has big
typewriter keys and the lights up so I
got him out last year which he uses Oh
No but no one can top the horse no yes
no one could top of Letterman's horse
that's just everyone's Everett's kind of
scared to give him again mm-hmm oh my
god oh no I'm getting shot at why no no
my brother no if they were brothers they
would be able to work on this then one
guy would just let the other guy go like
my woman tap tap tap tap yes yes that's
why you we did it good old goatee at
sideburns oh yeah there we go
Jamie oh my god now in a greenhouse
let's go
oh we're where do we go this way this
way wait I've got a hung up
it's one of those two-person garage
doors
[Music]
now here this way wait I forget my
inhale yeah
look at how shiny our shirts are no
shiny shiniest shirts there are these
guys are terrible shots clear weird
targets feeling very Shawshank mud well
there it is we beat the game we escaped
from the prison that felt great
we did it I want to get arrested now I'm
so amped up yeah I can do this yeah we
got to get arrested go back in and just
keep doing it if it was the 70s
well guys is one o'clock it's gonna do
it for us yeah for stream Coco Moses
norm everybody mowed the storm come see
up and up tonight with Moses storm a
dynasty typewriter in Los Angeles
California it's gonna be a great show
Pete Holmes Ron Funches Matt Braunger
so amazing Sun Chips comedy amazing
amazing a 45-minute bit while the most
roaming the theater it's gonna be quite
it's gonna like American Gladiators
you'll be head to toe in silver you will
be immediately insane it's a problem
tonight
hey the clocks in the mouth follow this
guy at Moses storm on everything
Instagram Facebook all these things and
of course go to at Team Coco on
Instagram or Facebook for a ticket link
to come see the show tonight thank you
guys for joining us see you guys let's
play everyone